Albert Einstein, la superstar des sciences.
Je pense que vraiment il mérite pas mal ce titre,
non seulement parce qu'il a révolutionné la physique
à de nombreuses reprises,
mais aussi parce que c'est un mec
qui était humainement très appréciable.
C'est vraiment une idole,
quelqu'un en lequel on s'identifie
et à qui on aimerait ressembler
quand on est scientifique.
Alors on dit souvent que Einstein
était mauvais élève à l'école
et je pense qu'il y a une part de vrai
dans le sens où
il était pas le bon élève à suivre,
à répondre à toutes les questions,
à lever la main, être assis au 1er rang,
des choses dans le genre...
Il était un élève qui était très très bon
en math et en physique,
mais qui un peu négligeait les autres matières
et avait un caractère un petit peu rebelle.
Qui finalement, est un trait assez récurrent
chez pas mal de grands génies
comme on en avait déjà parlé
avec la personne de John Nash.
Pour le coup, Einstein se fait pas vraiment remarquer
pour son génie quand il est étudiant
et à cause sûrement de son côté
un peu rebelle,
Einstein ne va pas avoir les bonnes lettres
de recommandation pour devenir un professeur.
Du coup, une fois qu'il a fini son doctorat
au Polytechnicum de Zurich,
il va être sans emploi.
À ce moment-là,
il va se marier avec Mileva Maric
et avoir un enfant en 1903-1904.
Et il finit du coup par devoir accepter un job,
il se fait pistonner pour l'avoir d'ailleurs,
et il devient employé de bureau
dans un bureau de brevets
où il doit valider ou invalider des brevets.
Bref, un travail qui correspond pas du tout
à son génie à priori,
mais ce travail lui donne l'occasion
de rêvasser,
de prendre le temps de réfléchir aux choses.
Et on dit souvent que parmi les brevets
qu'il avait à lire et à valider,
y en avait pas mal qui concernaient
la synchronisation des montres,
la méthode pour synchroniser les montres
qui était un gros problème à l'époque
puisque jusque là, les gens utilisaient des montres
qui correspondaient au soleil.
Donc il était midi
lorsque le soleil était en haut... au zénith.
Le problème avec cela, c'est que midi diffère
en fonction de la longitude.
Et du coup, entre Paris et Zurich,
ce n'est pas la même heure.
Et ça, ça posait des gros problèmes...
y avait des trains qui se percutaient et tout ça.
Du coup, synchroniser les montres,
c'était important.
Et Einstein a sans doute été très inspiré
par tous ces problèmes d'ingénierie
et s'est posé une question :
est-ce qu'il est vraiment possible
de synchroniser des montres ?
est-ce qu'il existe vraiment un temps universel ?
Je suis pas sûr qu'il ait vraiment posé les choses
dans cet ordre là,
toujours est-il qu'il en est revenu à se poser la question
de la nature du temps et de l'espace.
Ce qu'il fera dans la théorie de la relativité
en utilisant comme hypothèse
le fait que la vitesse de la lumière
est la même pour tous,
qu'il y ait une vitesse maximale de la causalité.
La raison pour laquelle il a supposé ça,
c'est parce qu'il interprète la théorie de Maxwell.
Quand on prend les équations de Maxwell,
??? la vitesse de la lumière reste la même.
Et Einstein se dit que c'est pas juste une étrangeté
de la théorie de Maxwell,
c'est peut-être quelque chose de fondamental
dans notre monde physique.
Alors la relativité restreinte, bien sûr, c'est un truc fou
comme on en a parlé dans l'épisode 5.
Mais aussi on a parlé pas mal de ses conséquences
comme par exemple la non additivité des vitesses
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 3,
les contractions des longueurs
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 4 puis après dans le 7
ou encore la dilatation du temps
dont on parlé dans l'épisode 23.
Et ce papier là tout seul,
c'est une révolution de la physique,
c'est un papier pour lequel Einstein
aurait été devenu incroyablement connu déjà.
C'était en 1905.
Mais en 1905, c'est l'année miraculeuse d'Einstein.
Une année absolument incroyable où ce papier là,
cette invention de la relativité restreinte,
n'était qu'une des quatre
très grandes découvertes de l'année.
Et le plus fou, c'est que les quatre découvertes
venaient d'une seule et même personne : Einstein.
Une autre découverte
qui est très reliée à la relativité restreinte,
puisqu'elle est une conséquence
de l'hypothèse selon laquelle
la vitesse de la lumière est la même pour tous,
c'est l'équation E = mc²
dont on parlé dans l'épisode 6
qui est une explication
de l'origine de la masse inertielle.
Et Einstein pose la question
qui paraît insensée au moment où il l'écrit,
qui paraît même insensée bien après
et dont on ne comprend vraiment tous les aspects
que bien plus récemment
notamment avec le mécanisme de Higgs
et la théorie QCD de la chromodynamique.
Einstein pose la question dans cet article,
c'est le titre :
est-ce que l'inertie d'un corps
ne serait pas juste une propriété émergente du fait
que avant tout,
les objets sont des concentrations de l'énergie ?
Et si on confine de l'énergie
en un point de l'espace-temps,
on obtient un truc qui est difficile à déplacer
dans le sens où la résistance à l'accélération
de cet objet est grande.
Et cette résistance à l'accélération,
ce qu'on appelle l'inertie,
c'est ce qu'on mesure avec la masse
qu'on appelle parfois "la masse inertielle."
Donc là, Einstein pose déjà la question
de l'origine de la masse.
Une question qui va revenir
de façon récurrente au cours du 20e siècle,
et que aujourd'hui encore
elle est pas tout à fait résolue.
Déjà il y a eu le mécanisme de Higgs
qui permet de donner de la masse
aux particules, aux fermions
et aux bosons,
mais il se trouve que la plupart de la masse de nos corps
ne vient pas de cette masse
à travers le mécanisme de Higgs,
la plupart de cette masse
vient du champ gluonique
et en fait, c'est même
un problème de recherche mathématique
que de prouver le fait
que le champ des gluons
acquiert bien de la masse
lorsqu'on confine à travers des "glue balls",
des boules de gluons.
Et ça, ça correspond
à l'un des sept problèmes du millénium,
la conjecture de Yang Mills.
Ok, donc ça fait déjà
deux théories révolutionnaires.
Une qui révolutionne l'espace-temps
et l'autre qui révolutionne la masse.
Ensuite Einstein va écrire un papier
sur le mouvement Brownien
qui va être la découverte... l'argument
qui va convaincre la communauté scientifique
de l'existence des atomes.
Et encore, l'idée est absolument incroyable.
Ces idées tellement "einsteiniennes."
Ce que fait Einstein, c'est qu'il étudie théoriquement
avec l'hypothèse de l'existence des atomes,
quelque chose de phénoménologique,
quelque chose qui a été observé
au début du 19e siècle,
donc 100 ans avant Einstein,
par un mec qui s'appelait Brown,
qu'on appelle du coup le mouvement brownien,
qui correspond au fait que lorsque vous mettez
des grains de pollen dans un verre d'eau,
même si le verre d'eau...
on a l'impression que l'eau ne bouge pas,
le grain de pollen, lui,
va bouger de façon erratique et chaotique.
Et Einstein explique cela par le fait
que l'eau est composée de plein de petites particules,
qu'on appellerait des molécules d'eau aujourd'hui,
qui vont dans tous les sens.
Et même si de façon globale, lorsqu'on moyennise
tout ça et qu'on regarde le verre d'eau,
on a l'impression que l'eau ne bouge pas,
en fait y a plein de particules qui vont dans tous les sens
et c'est ces particules là
qui en cognant les grain de pollen
vont faire bouger les grains de pollen
de façon erratique.
Et Einstein analyse
le mouvement des grains de pollen
pour inférer la taille des particules
et le nombre de particules.
Donc il calcule ainsi le nombre d'Avogadro.
Puis y a encore un autre papier
pour finir avec cette année merveilleuse,
miraculeuse.
C'est le papier sur la découverte des photons,
des atomes de lumière.
Le fait que la lumière
est composée d'atomes indivisibles.
Donc on appelle pas ça des atomes de lumière,
on appelle ça plutôt des quantas de lumière
ou des photons,
tout ça c'est des synonymes.
L'argument d'Einstein
pour l'existence des photons
est une explication de l'effet photoélectrique.
Donc l'effet photoélectrique,
ça correspond à un circuit qui a certaines propriétés.
Et ce qu'on a remarqué, c'est lorsqu'on éclaire
une plaque de métal dans le réseau,
dans le circuit électrique,
avec de la lumière bleue,
alors y a un courant qui est induit,
mais si on l'éclaire avec de la lumière rouge,
y a pas de courant qui est induit.
On pourrait se dire que c'est parce que la lumière rouge
est pas assez puissante.
Du coup, on pourrait
augmenter la puissance de la lumière rouge.
On pourrait mettre une lumière rouge
extrêmement puissante.
Mais ce qu'on observe, c'est que peu importe
la puissance de la lumière rouge
elle n'induit pas de courant électrique
alors que on peut mettre
un tout petit peu de lumière bleue
ça va créer un courant électrique.
Et l'explication d'Einstein,
c'est que la lumière est faite de photons,
de petits grains de lumière,
de photons indivisibles,
et chaque photon possède une énergie
qui dépend de sa couleur.
Les photons bleus, eux,
ont beaucoup d'énergie
et du coup il vont pouvoir exciter
les électrons des atomes et les arracher des atomes
alors que les lumières rouges,
il peut y avoir beaucoup de photons
aucun de ces photons n'aura l'énergie suffisante
pour, lui, tirer les électrons d'un atome.
J'ai un petit peu parlé de ces photons
dans l'épisode 8
qui permettait aussi
d'introduire les espaces vectoriels.
Et donc cette année en 1905,
Einstein publie ces quatre papiers
qui chacun mérite son prix Nobel,
chacun révolutionne vraiment la physique.
C'est quatre papiers vraiment merveilleux.
Je sais même pas lequel des quatre est mon préféré.
Mais tout passe complètement inaperçu.
Personne ne cite Einstein,
personne ne soutient Einstein,
personne ne demande à rencontrer Einstein.
Et pendant deux ans, Einstein
il continue à valider des brevets
tel un mec lambda, inconnu quoi.
Ça l'empêche pas de rêvasser
et en 1907,
alors qu'il est encore
dans son bureau des brevets,
il va rêvasser
à un mec qui tombe d'un immeuble,
comme on en a parlé dans l'épisode 17,
et il va se dire
que quelqu'un qui tombe d'un bâtiment
est en chute libre, est en apesanteur
et ne sent plus la pesanteur
du coup, il n'y a plus de gravité
dans son référentiel.
Et là il se dit :
"ah, mais tiens ça c'est le bon référentiel,
c'est un référentiel qui ne nécessite pas
que l'on invente une force de gravité."
Donc cette accélération vers le haut du sol,
C'est vraiment une idée absolument lumineuse qu'il va...
c'est ce qu'il va appeler
l'idée la plus heureuse de sa vie.
Je vous invite à aller voir l'épisode 19
où j'en parle pas mal.
Mais surtout l'épisode My4Cents
sur l'accélération vers le haut du sol.
Encore une fois, à travers ces vidéos,
je cherche pas à vous convaincre d'une vérité,
à la limite ça je m'en fous,
ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est vous faire réfléchir à cette idée,
mais surtout vous rendre heureux
en philosophant sur cette idée absolument lumineuse.
Bon alors il a cette idée
absolument heureuse,
mais, comme vous l'imaginez,
ça convainc personne
surtout qu'il a pas encore une théorie
??? de l'espace du temps...
Du coup, il y a des trucs qui marchent pas.
Il a l'impression que la Terre grossit...
Et en effet, en 1907,
Einstein est pas allé plus loin dans cette théorie
parce qu'il voyait le problème
de la Terre qui grossit, sans doute,
mais il sentait qu'il avait quelque chose
d'important là,
il sentait qu'il y avait quelque chose
qu'il fallait développer.
L'année suivante, il se fait enfin repérer,
notamment par Max Planck.
Max Planck qui a déjà travaillé
sur des idées similaires aux photons,
même si Max Planck
était quand même pas mal à côté de la plaque
et qu'il croyait même pas à ce qu'il écrivait.
Max Planck reconnaît quand même
le génie d'Einstein
pour avoir bien pensé les choses
et du coup le recommande.
Et puis Einstein va enfin avoir
des propositions académiques
qui correspondent à son génie.
D'abord à Berne puis à Berlin
où il va travailler notamment
sur quelques problèmes de mécanique quantique,
rien de très révolutionnaire
à ce moment là.
Et il garde quand même
dans un coin de sa tête
ce problème d'accélération
vers le haut du sol.
Il médite, il médite, il médite ça...
Et puis, sans doute,
alors je sais pas exactement
à quel moment il est venu...
J'ai pas trouvé de bon document
qui expliquait comment Einstein
en est venu à être persuadé
de la courbure de l'espace du temps.
En tout cas,
rien de très convaincant à mon sens.
Mais moi, j'imagine l'hypothèse
la plus probable à mon sens,
c'est que il s'est dit
que ces observateurs en chute libre
sont dans les bons référentiels,
ces référentiels sont inertiels,
mais c'est des référentiels
qui sont en accélération, à priori,
les uns par rapport aux autres.
Et là Einstein se dit :
il doit y avoir une façon de dire
qu'en fait on ne peut pas comparer
des référentiels inertiels
qui sont trop éloignés
les uns des autres.
Et ça, ça correspond exactement
à dire que l'espace-temps est courbe
comme j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode 18
et dans les commentaires de l'épisode 24.
Du coup,
il commence à être petit à petit persuadé
que sa solution,
c'est une courbure de l'espace-temps.
Sauf qu'à l'époque,
y a pas beaucoup d'experts mondiaux
qui maîtrisent la géométrie riemanienne.
Il en connaît un, c'est Marcel Grossmann
qui était son professeur au polytecnicum de Zurich
dont il séchait les cours.
Du coup, il retourne à Zurich
pour travailler avec Grossmann
sur une théorie de la courbure de l'espace-temps
comme j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode 20.
Donc avec Grossman,
ils arrivent à développer une théorie
et en 1913, Einstein et Grossmann
publient une nouvelle théorie de la gravité
qui passe par cette idée
de courbure de l'espace-temps.
Ensuite en 1914,
y a la 1ere guerre mondiale qui éclate.
Et à voir cette 1ere guerre mondiale, déjà...
chacun des camps
se préparait à la 1ere guerre mondiale.
Et du coup, Einstein observe certains de ses collègues
qu'il admirait, comme Max Planck,
se mettre à mettre en place,
à construire de nouvelles armes,
de plus en plus meurtrières
et Einstein déteste ça, il est affolé.
Il essaie de lancer une pétition
au sein de la communauté scientifique
pour dire non à la guerre,
mais y a pas beaucoup de signatures
et il est complètement stupéfait
de toute cette technologie,
de toutes ces sciences qui sont utilisées
pour tuer d'autres personnes.
Le pire étant sans doute Haber Fritz
dont e-penser a parlé dans cet épisode.
Une autre chose qui va se passer, c'est que Einstein
pour promouvoir sa théorie va faire un peu...
il va aller à différents endroits en Europe,
enfin en Allemagne en particulier,
il va aller à Berlin et puis à Göttingen.
Du coup, il va se séparer spatialement de Mileva,
de sa femme.
Cet éloignement spatial
va se traduire ensuite en un éloignement émotionnel
puisqu'ils vont finir par se séparer
et par divorcer des années après.
Comme Einstein semble avoir perdu
la guerre contre les pro-guerre,
Einstein trouve refuge dans la physique
et va se lancer à ce moment là pleinement
dans l'étude plus détaillée
de sa théorie de la relativité.
Il va se rendre compte notamment
que la théorie qu'il a développée avec Grossman
ne tient pas la route
et puis il va aller à gauche à droite
en parler avec d'autres scientifiques,
essayer de trouver des solutions.
Et il raconte dans une lettre que le seul qui est arrivé
à le suivre dans ses raisonnements,
c'est un certain David Hilbert.
Et à ce moment-là,
une course commence entre les deux grands génies,
entre Einstein et Hilbert,
pour savoir qui sera le premier
à trouver la bonne équation de la relativité générale.
Alors ce que je n'ai pas raconté
dans l'épisode 20,
c'est qu'en fait, c'est Hilbert
qui est le premier à trouver la bonne équation
et il publie ça trois jours avant Einstein
qui publie aussi la bonne équation,
mais le fait que le papier de Hilbert
est incomplet, imprécis, il est à réécrire
et du coup, Hilbert va reconnaître que Einstein
est le père de cette théorie,
il va donner tous les crédits à Einstein
et il va dire que c'est la théorie d'Einstein.
La théorie de la relativité générale,
c'est la théorie d'Einstein.
Et ce qui est marrant, c'est qu'Hilbert
va se mettre à directement enseigner la théorie
en disant :
"tiens, voici ce qu'a découvert Einstein."
Comme si c'était déjà une théorie établie,
ce qui est vraiment marrant
puisqu'à ce moment là à priori
y a aucune preuve expérimentale.
Mais d'un côté le fait qu'elle explique
la trajectoire de mercure,
mais surtout la consistance,
l'élégance mathématique de cette théorie
fait que ces deux génies là
qui ont beaucoup étudié la question
sont persuadés de sa véracité
avant même toute observation expérimentale.
Ce qui est quand même assez intéressant
d'un point de vue épistémologique
de voir l'importance de l'élégance mathématique,
en tout cas auprès de ces génies.
Et moi, personnellement, je suis complètement séduit aussi par les arguments d'Einstein.
À ce moment-là, je pense que si j'avais compris
tout ce qu'avait dit Einstein à ce moment-là
j'aurais été moi aussi persuadé
de la validité de cette théorie.
C'est juste une théorie trop trop trop belle,
la relativité générale.
Contrairement à la mécanique quantique.
L'observation expérimentale qui va confirmer
la relativité générale d'Einstein,
c'est celle d'Eddington,
comme on a parlé dans l'épisode 20.
Mais ce dont je n'ai pas parlé
dans l'épisode 20,
c'est que y avait beaucoup
de remises en cause
de "la preuve expérimentale" d'Eddington,
notamment pour des raisons politiques.
Il faut savoir que Eddington
était anglais et pacifiste.
Du coup, pour Eddington,
il trouvait ça absolument génial
pour le futur du monde,
pour restaurer la paix dans le monde
et un peu unifier tous ces peuples
qui s'en foutent plein la gueule,
de tous ces problèmes de nationalisme.
Eddington se dit que la science,
et la physique en particulier,
peut être la chose qui va unifier tous les peuples
et transcender ces identitarismes nationalistes
qui, selon Eddington et Einstein,
sont les causes de la guerre.
C'est pour ça que Eddington
était si motivé pour aller faire les observations,
mais c'est aussi pour ça
que d'autres personnes ont supposé
que Eddington avait faussé un petit peu
ses mesures,
ou du moins avait été victime
de façon plus ou moins consciente
d'un certain biais.
C'est très difficile,
il y a des biais cognitifs qui son très difficiles.
Même si on connaît les biais cognitifs,
c'est très difficile de s'en séparer.
D'autant qu'au même moment,
y avait un observateur américain,William Campbell,
qui avait fait les mêmes mesures,
mais avait conclu l'exact opposé.
Il avait rejeté
la théorie de la relativité générale d'Einstein.
Donc c'est assez marrant
parce qu'en 1919,
tous les journaux titrent
Einstein a tué Newton et tout ça....
Tout le monde met Einstein en superstar,
mais dans la communauté scientifique,
on ne sait pas encore.
Les gens sont encore très dubitatifs.
Einstein n'est pas encore vraiment une superstar
dans le monde académique
alors qu'il l'est déjà dans le monde
non académique, c'est assez marrant.
Donc finalement, en 1921,
Campbell, cette fois, fait des mesures
vraiment nettes, précises, convaincantes
et confirme
la théorie de la relativité générale d'Einstein.
Einstein gagne du coup le prix Nobel en 1921,
mais pas pour ses travaux sur la relativité générale,
il le gagne pour ses travaux pour ses travaux
sur la découverte du photon.
Et le plus fou dans toute cette histoire,
c'est que suite à ce prix Nobel,
ses découvertes tout ça...
Il va y avoir une nouvelle génération de scientifiques
qui vont vouloir suivre les pas d'Einstein
et vont embrasser la physique
plutôt que de s'engager dans l'armée ou autre...
Les gens croient en les sciences
à ce moment-là,
les sciences sont devenues quelque chose
d'incroyablement sexy à cette époque.
Du coup, on a toute une génération de Dirac, Schrödinger, Heinsenberg, Pauli...
Max Born, de Broglie, Majorana...
Fermi
et puis surtout un certain Niels Bohr
qui va devenir le nouveau Némésis d'Einstein.
Donc tous ces gens là
vont développer  au cours des années 20-30
la théorie de la mécanique quantique
qui va super bien marcher,
expliquer plein de faits expérimentaux,
mais qui va extrêmement déranger Einstein.
Einstein a toujours cru à la mécanique quantique,
mais son problème
c'est pas la véracité de la mécanique quantique,
c'est le fait que ce n'est pas une théorie fondamentale.
En effet, la mécanique quantique
utilise des probabilités
pour prédire certains évènements
et Einstein dit que l'utilisation des probabilités
est une preuve de notre ignorance.
On utilise des probabilités
parce que y a quelque chose qu'on a pas compris
et du coup, lorsqu’on moyennise,
finalement la théorie effectivement marche,
mais si on était capables de décrire
plus en profondeur les particules et tout ça,
on serait selon Einstein capables de tout prédire.
C'est ce qu'il va appeler
la théorie des variables cachées.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des variables,
des trucs en plus dans la théorie
qu'on n'a pas encore introduits
dans nos modèles théorique.
Et qui vont être capables
d'enlever les probabilités de la mécanique quantique.
Ça correspond
à ce qu'Einstein avait écrit dans une lettre,
le fait que Dieu ne joue pas aux dés.
En particulier, y a un problème
qui gênait beaucoup Einstein
et qui personnellement
me dérange beaucoup aussi,
et je pense qu'il dérange
beaucoup d'autres physiciens...
peut-être pas assez à mon sens...
Quelque chose que je trouve très bizarre,
c'est le problème de la mesure.
Le fait que lorsqu'on mesure quelque chose,
lorsqu'on observe un objet quantique,
son état quantique se modifie.
L'observation affecte l'état quantique
de ce qu'on observe.
Et ça, Einstein ça le révolte complètement.
Bohr se dit juste : "C'est la théorie, c'est comme ça."
Il cherche pas à savoir plus en profondeur.
Et Einstein dit :
"Y a un truc qui marche pas, y a un truc bizarre."
Il faut réussir à mieux l'expliquer,
faut faire une théorie qui non seulement prédit bien
mais qui en plus doit vraiment avoir un sens,
un sens derrière tout ça.
Einstein disait :
"J'aime penser que la lune est là,
même lorsque je ne la regarde pas."
Ça correspond à dire
que si on est complètement Bohr,
si on suit ce qu'on appelle
"l'interprétation de Copenhague"
parce que Bohr est danois.
Si on en croit l'interprétation de Copenhague,
les objets n'ont vraiment leur état
que lorsqu'on les observe
et du coup, lorsqu'on observa pas la lune,
elle peut être dans un état quantique
qui n'est pas le même
que lorsqu'on l'observe.
Et du coup, elle apparaît vraiment
selon l’interprétation de Copenhague
poussée à son extrême,
la lune n'apparaît vraiment
que lorsqu'on la regarde.
Ce qui est très bizarre.
Du coup, Einstein va à plusieurs reprises
essayer d'attaquer la mécanique quantique
en montrant qu'il y a un truc
qu'on n'a pas compris.
Il y a plusieurs attaques qui fait ça
et à chaque fois,
Bohr doit beaucoup réfléchir
pour résoudre ces paradoxes un par un.
Et le plus mythique de tout cela,
c'est sans doute celui
de la conférence de Solvay en 1930.
Einstein propose l'expérience suivante :
prenez une boîte fermée avec une petite fenêtre,
mais fenêtre fermée au début
et puis vous ouvrez la fenêtre
pendant un court instant
du coup y a peut être
quelques photons qui sont sortis
et si y a des photons
qui sortent de la boîte,
ça veut dire que comme E = mc²,
ça veut dire que ces photons-là
ont enlevé de l'énergie,
du coup y a moins d'énergie dans la boîte
et la masse de la boîte devrait avoir diminué.
Sauf que Einstein dit
que la variation de la masse,
donc l'énergie qui est partie,
ça, à priori, on peut le mesurer
avec  une précision arbitraire.
On peut mesurer avec une très grande précision
la masse de la boîte
avant d'avoir ouvert la fente
et on peut mesurer avec grande précision
la masse de la boîte
après avoir ouverte la fente.
Donc l'incertitude que l'on a
sur l'énergie qu'il y a à l'intérieur de la boîte,
est en fait aussi petite que l'on veut
alors que la durée d'ouverture de la fente
est également aussi petite que l'on veut.
Du coup le produit
entre l'incertitude sur le temps d'ouverture
et l'incertitude sur l'énergie qui s'en est allée,
ça à priori, on peut le rendre
aussi petit que l'on veut.
Et ça, ça contredit les principes fondamentaux
de la physique quantique
et en particulier
le principe d'étalement de Heisenberg.
Y en a qui l'appellent principe d'incertitude,
moi je préfère appeler ça principe d'étalement.
Rosenfeld a écrit à ce sujet,
c'était un vrai choc pour Bohr
qui n'avait pas de solution à ce problème d'Einstein,
et pendant le reste de la soirée au congrès,
il était incroyablement agité
et  il continuait de passer
d'un scientifique à l'autre
afin de chercher à les persuader
que ce que disait Einstein ne pouvait pas être vrai,
mais ils avaient pas de bons arguments.
Et que ce serait la fin de la physique
si Einstein avait raison.
Ça détruisait complètement en tout cas
la physique quantique.
Mais Bohr n'arrivait pas à trouver de façon
de résoudre le paradoxe.
"Je ne pourrai jamais oublier l'image
des deux antagonistes,
ça c'est Rosenfeld qui parle,
"au moment où ils ont quitté le congrès.
"Einstein avec son grand air confiant,
"avec sa tranquilité
et son rire un peu ironique.
"Bohr complètement agité à côté de lui
qui arrêtait pas de bouger dans tous les sens avec grande excitation."
À ce moment-là,
on avait l'impression qu'Einstein avait gagné,
mais Rosenfeld rajoute :
"Le matin suivant,
ce fut le triomphe de Bohr."
L'explication de Bohr est un peu technique.
Son grand défi,
c'est de  relier l'incertitude sur la variation de masse
à une incertitude
sur le temps d'ouverture de la fenêtre.
Et là, la beauté du raisonnement de Bohr,
c'est qu'il va utiliser
la théorie de la relativité générale d'Einstein
en disant que lorsqu'on cherche
à peser la boîte,
on peut utiliser par exemple une balance,
mais l'incertitude sur la position
fait que il y a incertitude sur la mesure de la masse.
En fait, on peut pas mesurer la masse
de façon infiniment précise,
en tout cas pas si on cherche à mesurer
en utilisant l'accélération des référentiels.
Sauf que du coup,
si on fait ça par exemple sur Terre,
l'incertitude sur la hauteur de la boîte
correspond à des variations
de la dilatation gravitationnelle du temps.
Et cette variation
sur la dilatation gravitationnelle du temps
créé une incertitude sur la mesure du temps
qui est donc liée à la position.
L'argument est juste incroyable.
Bohr utilise la relativité générale
pour résoudre le paradoxe de mécanique quantique
qu'avait posé Einstein.
C'est juste lumineux.
Ceci dit,
la bataille Bohr-Einstein n'est pas finie
et on va en parler
dans notre débat à la fin de cette vidéo.
En 1933, le régime nazi
accède au pouvoir en Allemagne
et puis Einstein,
qui est pacifiste mais aussi juif,
est contraint de s'échapper
et il va fuir aux États-Unis,
notamment à Princeton University,
où il va former une espèce de dream team
??
avec notamment Levon ??, Gödel,
Herman Weyl
ou encore Pauli, Wolfgang Pauli.
Et à cette occasion,
il va acquérir la 6e nationalité de sa vie,
ce qui est assez incroyable
pour quelqu'un qui aimait pas le nationalisme.
Enfin, je pense que justement c'est lié.
Plus on a de nationalités,
moins on a de sentiment nationaliste.
Il a commencé avec la nationalité
du royaume de Gutenberg,
puis il est devenu apatride,
puis suisse, puis austro-hongrois,
puis prusse,
prusse c'est allemand quoi,
et enfin il est devenu américain
en allant aux États-Unis à Princeton.
Il va écrire ensuite une lettre
au président Roosevelt des États-Unis
pour lancer un projet de bombe nucléaire,
ce qu'on appellera le projet Manhattan.
Einstein avait notamment peur
que du côté Nazi,
notamment un mec comme Heisenberg,
n'en vienne à construire cette bombe nucléaire
avant les américains.
Mais Einstein finira par regretter
ses recherches sur la bombe nucléaire
et surtout son utilisation
à Hiroshima et Nagasaki.
Et enfin, en 1935, le paradoxe EPR,
qui est un énorme chapitre
dans la rivalité Einstein vs Bohr,
où Einstein va gagner le débat,
à mon sens en tout cas.
Il va écrire un papier
absolument incroyable
dans lequel il va montrer
que en construisant des particules intriquées
en les éloignant de très loin,
ces particules intriquées,
si on en croit la mécanique quantique,
de base en tout cas,
elles devraient avoir une interaction à distance
plus rapide que la vitesse de la lumière.
Et du coup, Einstein dit que ça,
c'est contradictoire avec la relativité restreinte.
Du coup, la mécanique quantique,
telle qu'elle était formulée
dans l'interprétation de Copenhague
est incomplète
et il propose notamment
de rajouter des variables cachées
qui déterminent la manière
dont les particules vont être observées
au moment où les particules
se sont séparées et pas après,
ce qu'on appelle
la théorie des variables cachées locales.
Et là, c'est le triomphe d'Einstein,
l'argument est implacable.
Je pense qu'à ce moment là,
n'importe quel théoricien qui réfléchit à cette question
donne raison à Einstein.
Sauf que l'histoire est plus compliquée,
plus merveilleuse encore que tout ça.
Puisque dans les années 50,
il y a eu un mathématicien, John Bell,
qui a découvert des inégalités de Bell
qui permettent de distinguer
entre la théorie des variables cachées locales d'Einstein
et l’interprétation de Copenhague
de la mécanique quantique.
Et John Bell va donner une façon de mesurer ça,
bon il va falloir attendre
les progrès technologiques pour y arriver,
mais dans les années 80,
si je me trompe pas,
les expériences d'Alain Aspect
vont montrer que Einstein avait tort,
car en fait son interaction à distance,
plus rapide en un certain sens
que la vitesse de la lumière,
mais ça ne contredit pas
le principe de relativité
et la vitesse maximale de la lumière,
parce qu'il n'est pas possible
d'influencer le résultat de l'autre
en modifiant l'état de l'un.
Et du coup, il est pas possible d'envoyer d'informations
plus rapide que la vitesse de la lumière.
Mais c'est vraiment, vraiment subtile.
On peut dire que Einstein s'est trompé,
mais avec raison.
Comme je l'ai dit dans l'épisode sur les erreurs :
"à dire vrai sans raison,
on triomphe sans gloire
"et à dire faux avec raison,
en tout cas c'est ce que je pense,
on s'incline avec une gloire triomphante."